endlich mal ein bisschen deko hier hallo
mein name ist luca und wir spielen heute
das spiel so motor edreams vor weil ich
habe mir da die vollversion gekauft ich
musste das ganze bild leider ein
bisschen strecken damit auf eine hd
weiter passt weil das sonst irgendwie so
ein kleines rahmen ist deswegen ist es
jetzt so dass wenn ich hierhin clique
der ball aber wieder rechts und fliegt
und
ja ich mache einfach mal versus
alles gleich wie diverse computer mano
die kauferinger selection ich glaube
wenn ich hierhin schieße dann muss ich
ja genau us-computer- und jetzt ist den
start match up of forward backspace
potenter pusch einst hart es geht schon
los
daun startmatch abbog forward backspace
push push 1
mich gewonnen das war somit der beste
kampf den ich bisher hatte luca
mein charakter trägt einfach gerade der
andere läuft der dort gerade jeden und
nicht leute einfach wieder spaß
ich laufe direkt auf ihn los und dann
mache ich pusch einen cent höher
also das coole an dem spiel ist nicht
dieses kämpft man sich sondern einfach
was danach passiert ist blut gewonnen
nein nein nein nein der macht immer
alles kaputt dieser moment wenn man
betrunken ist und sich einfach hinlegen
will
dieser moment wenn man betrunken ist und
den freunden zeigen will haye ich kann
noch richtig gerade stehen
aber ich darf dieses spiel nicht so zu
grunde machen wir sagen immer alles luca
das dauert so lange bis man sowas
entwickelt hat macht das mal es geht los
hier den grauen mache ich doch direkter
ich hab verloren dieses spiel ist viel
zu lässig wird das übels gerne mal gegen
andere youtuber spielt verdammt ich bin
schon wieder zweiter freunde ich säge
ich kann auch weiterlaufen
irgendwie gerade wie geil ist das denn
bäume das spiel macht unglaublich viel
spaß ich würde das volk entgegen anderer
runter von mir um mein gott ich kann
auch noch weiterlaufen meldet grauer
nein nein wieso machen alles kaputt ich
will einfach mal sehen was passiert wenn
ich den abhang runter fall aber ich
glaube ich komm nicht mal so weit wir
kommen schon lukas ist ein weiter weg
aber wir werden es zusammen schaffen es
kann nicht so schwer sein darunter
und der graue kommt mir jetzt nach oder
wie
ich glaube dass spieler zerstört aber es
gibt ja noch andere modi und zwar zwei
player versus zwei computer you and
you're in zwei computer drückt mir die
daumen freunde ich bin immer noch der
blaue und muss sie weiterkommen schon
luca vanni
das war gemein das war jetzt also
wirklich gemeint sind die arbeiten
zusammen weil das ist echt einfach ein
reinstes dumm
das ist eigentlich genau mein humor die
bühne
ich lasse euch jetzt einfach mal
zuschauen wie ihr den zuschauern wie die
die map kaputt machen und in der
zwischenzeit
wir machen den kalender auch heute ist
der 14
deswegen machen wir das vierzehnte
türchen auf und wir haben eine pflanze
endlich mal ein bisschen deko hier
ich habe keine ahnung ob ich das jetzt
gerade richtig zusammengebaut haben aber
bei mir sieht die pflanze so aus ist
aber eigentlich ganz schön oder
die kommen jetzt auch toll in unser
kleines
hier so sieht das übrigens bei mir die
ganze zeit aus und damit will ich sagen
nein great gray
jetzt muss ich das video beenden wenn
euch das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen wollte
dass ich das nochmal zocke vielleicht
gegen den anderen youtuber oder nem
kumpel oder
gegen meine mutter
wenn ihr davon mehr möchte dann steckt
euch einen bleistift auf das ohr
dreht euch um und schreit ganz oft banal